[Musique]
parce que nicolas dupont aignan qui
conduit notre liste se bat depuis 20 ans
pour alerter dénoncé dans la droite
ligne de la filiation de philippe seguin
sur les dangers de ce modèle-là de
construction européenne de cette union
européenne technocratique
bureaucratiques qui est ruineuse pour
les peuples et notamment pour la france
et que donc nicolas dupont aignan a
toujours été très visionnaire sur tout
ce qu'il a dénoncé ce sur quoi il a
alerté et aujourd'hui et bien tout ce
qui se produit et nous l'avions prédit
prévu cette union européenne que l'on
nous fait volontairement amalgamé avec
l'europe mais qui n'est pas l'europe
cette union européenne qui est donc la
structure supranationale basé à
bruxelles technocratique
antidémocratique puisque nos élus un
commission européenne bruxelles banque
centrale européenne cour européenne de
justice cette organisation nous pensons
donc qu'il faut la sortir de l'europe il
faut sortir l'union européenne de
l'europe et revenir à une construction
européenne à un modèle qui ne soit pas
un modèle ultra libéral qui ne soit pas
soumis à des intérêts étrangers à
washington à berlin soumis à la chine
union européenne qui a échoué sur tous
les tableaux qui n'a rien construit
aucun grand projet nous n'avons pas été
capables ils n'ont pas été capables de
bâtir des concurrents aux gars femmes
par exemple dans le numérique alors
c'est un enjeu essentiel
p le défi majeur c'est vraiment de
renverser la table à bruxelles et à
strasbourg pour faire en sorte que
l'europe
enfin se préoccuper résolvent les grands
enjeux qui sont devant nous c'est à dire
l'emploi la relocalisation de deux
millions d'emplois pour stopper ce libre
échange fous ces politiques d'austérité
et de libre échange intégral qui sont
seize détruisent nos normes sociales
environnementales sanitaires en laissant
rentrer n'importe quel produit depuis
les états unis ou la chine dans des
marchés où ici nous interdisons à nos
propres industries ou agriculteurs de
produire de cette manière par exemple la
première chose que nous ferons c'est de
bloquer le budget de l'union européenne
car nous voulons que la france ne donne
plus 11 milliards net je dis bien nettes
c'est à dire l on donne 22 milliards
tous les ans elle en récupère 11 inclus
là la patte d'ailleurs nous voulons
revenir au niveau
de monsieur chirac à l'époque nous
donnions 2 milliards d'euros à l'union
européenne
[Musique]